every adult in america could soon be
eligible for a coveted booster shot
pfizer and its partner biontech have
asked federal regulators to expand the
reach of their booster shot to anyone
ages 18 and older that could include
people who did not get the pfizer
vaccine for their first two doses
interesting stuff nikki batiste has more
more than 25 million americans have
gotten their covid vaccine booster shot
the fda authorized it for adults who are
65 and older at high risk or who already
received the johnson johnson vaccine now
pfizer is asking the fda to authorize
its booster shot for everyone 18 and
older citing it's new data that a
booster shot offers close to complete
protection from severe covid the data
look excellent it showed real safety and
it showed that it worked over 95 percent
protection from infection the fda denied
a request by pfizer to expand
eligibility for its booster back in
september saying there wasn't enough
information at that time but mounting
evidence now shows without a booster the
vaccine's effectiveness drops over time
i think it's certainly important as we
go into colder months as dr david agus
says there's concern about cases rising
this winter about a third of americans
haven't even had one vaccine dose what
we're seeing is rising numbers of cases
in areas where the temperature is
dropping because people are moving
indoors more and there's more spread of
the virus and we're seeing more
breakthrough infections and obviously
significant infections than those who
are unvaccinated
dr aegis says pfizer's request will go
straight to the fda commissioner who
could rule on it as soon as next week if
authorized pfizer's booster shot would
be available for all adults and dr agus
recommends all adults should get it even
if they got the boderna or jnj vaccine
that's interesting just gives you
another weapon in the arsenal yeah sure
it does fight covet making strange all
right nikki thank you very much